this is real footage captured outside a
micro center computer store in dallas
texas and you might think that twitch
streamer preston a lewis was filming a
black friday shopping rush or something
but no
no one in this crowd of people was
hoping for a discount
at all
the shortage of gpus has gotten so dire
that this
is how desperate people are just to buy
a graphics card at an msrp that has
already been twice inflated since the
release of nvidia's 30 series once by
component shortages then again by
tariffs on u.s imports from china which
makes nvidia's pricing for the new 3070
ti
really confusing because 599 for this
much raw power
that would have been a decent deal even
before the shortage and what makes it
especially unexpected is that last
week's 3080 ti was also competitively
priced
but only in the context of the current
landscape where this untested 2080 ti on
ebay sold for a thousand us dollars is
nvidia trying to start street brawls
or did they travel to an alternate
timeline and bring this thing back for
the good of all gamers
and if they did
just how good is it
and who's our sponsor
antlion audio their modmic wireless
microphone delivers best in class audio
quality 12 plus hours of battery life
and it magnetically mounts to almost any
pair of headphones get 15 off the mod
mic wireless another mod mic product at
the link in the video description
[Music]
599 puts the 3070 ti smack dab in the
middle of the rtx 3070 and rtx 3080 both
in terms of price and product
positioning which
in itself makes sense because unlike the
rtx 3080 ti which was pretty much a
watered-down rtx 3090 the rtx 3070 ti is
more of a beefed up rtx 30 70. it shares
the same ga104 gpu with about four
percent more course with the same eight
gigs of gddr6 memory on the same 256-bit
bus
pretty unexciting
or i'm sorry did i say the same gddr6
memory what i should have probably
mentioned is that it is much faster
clocking in at a good 2.5 gigahertz
higher we are looking at an effective
bandwidth boost of
160 gigabytes per second which is nearly
a 24
increase
consequently the rated graphics power is
a hefty 70 watts higher and the cooler
is a new ambiguous design that looks
something like a cross between the rtx
3080 and rtx 3070 with the same totally
necessary and very industry standard
12-pin connector though at least two
nvidia's credit they were kind enough to
angle it instead of having it stick
straight out like the old 30 70.
so the hope then both for nvidia and for
the rest of us is that if the cooler is
in between the two cards the rtx 37 etis
performance will be as well despite it
having just four percent more course
than its namesake and a whopping 29
fewer cores than the rtx 3080.
now since the testing is happening so
soon after our rtx 3080ti review we're
going to be using the same bench in the
same patch state and we'll even be
wearing the same shirt and the same
underwear from lttstore.com
freshly washed of course though
starting with metro exodus enhanced
edition the story is already looking
pretty interesting for the 30-70 ti it
managed an average frame rate 12 higher
than the 30-70 which is good
but then that also puts it a good 19
lower than the rtx 3080 which is
hmm
f1 2020 tightens the spread somewhat
though with a 10 lead over the 30 70 and
a 12 loss against the 3080 and forza
horizon 4 actually continues along this
trajectory giving us the best result yet
so it appears that high frame rates
favor the 37 eti's additional memory
bandwidth while lower frame rates
really want for more cores and this
appears to bear out an assassin's creed
valhalla where frame rates dip way back
down to earth and actually amd's rx 6700
xt manages to eclipse not only the 3070
and 370ti but even the 30 80. cs go is
another chance for the 3070 ti's
lightning fast memory to make up ground
but while it manages to get close to the
middle of the 30 70 and 3080 it ends up
closer to the former
not gonna lie though given that we're
looking at a handful of extra cores and
a hefty memory overclock
i'm pretty impressed
but how much are those going to help if
you want to do anything other than
gaming
as it turns out
not much
the rtx 3070 ti doesn't manage much in
the way of an improvement over the rtx
3070 and loses badly to the rtx 3080 in
rendering with both blender and v-ray
while creative cloud doesn't really show
enough variation between the cards to
warrant picking up one over the other
octane bench is a little better than
blender but we're still looking at a
much closer result to the 3070 than to
the 3080 and this trend continues pretty
hardcore into spec view perf where the
rtx 3080 stomps all over both of its ga
104 equipped competitors
the only thing that could be considered
a win here is the energy benchmark where
the 3070 ti's additional memory
bandwidth pushes it far enough away from
the 3070 to find that middle ground
again
so
what have we learned then it turns out
that fast memory on a gpu can be good
very good but that it's also very
situational and we also learned that
fast memory with more cores is better
than just fast memory in every
conceivable way
okay we didn't really learn either of
those things but it's always nice to get
a refresher isn't it
and on that subject let's talk cooling
the bigger heatsink on the rtx 3070 ti
founders edition meant that it didn't
get all that much hotter than the rtx
3070 and with a peak of just a little
higher than 78 degrees and an average of
64 degrees across our spec view perf
test we're looking at a respectable
result all things considered
power consumption however is less so the
37 eti ends up sitting much closer to
the 30 80 than its performance would
suggest at 311 watts peak and 151 watts
average that's about 20 more power draw
than its non-ti cousin and most of this
appears to come from the up-clocked
memory considering how few additional
gpu cores there are and the fact that
when we look at core clocks the 3070 ti
consistently runs about 100 megahertz
lower than both the 3070 and the 3080.
at the end of the day though our
recommendation like with the rtx 3080ti
is going to be to immediately buy this
card at msrp if you can
and i know that not everyone agreed with
our conclusion last time but the truth
is i stand behind what i said 100
because no matter who you are are you a
filthy scalper looking to make a quick
buck or are you a gamer who happens to
have that much money to spend on a
graphics card
whichever one you are
both of the new ti variants
at msrp of course are going to be a much
better deal than anything that you're
getting on the secondary market and sure
you can compare these cards to suggested
pricing from a year ago but the reality
of the situation is that outside of the
handful of cards that nvidia sells
through their web store
those cards at those prices
they don't actually exist
and that might make you mad but shooting
the messenger isn't going to get you
anywhere and besides i did warn you
after all
so
yeah
it's a great gpu with great nvidia
features like dlss high quality hardware
video encoding and more and 5.99
it's an absolute bargain for this class
of gpu in the current conditions
will the 37 eti still make sense when
the dust settles
honestly my money's on not really but i
suppose only time can tell for sure
and by the look of things
it's going to be a long time
but it won't be a long time until i tell
you about our sponsor drop's alt
mechanical keyboard is based on their
top selling control keyboard and
features fully programmable keys so you
can assign macros or keybinds to
whatever you want they removed the
function row to reduce it to 67 keys
instead of 87 and it's created with a
solid aluminum frame and a hot swap
switch plate making it super easy to
change out your switches it's both
portable and rock solid and features a
customizable rgb backlight and
undergliding as well as two usbc
connectors with one on each side of the
keyboard whatever works best for your
cable management so pick up your own
drop alt keyboard at the link down below
and you'll get a free set of skylight
keycaps today using promo code free caps
at the checkout so thanks for watching
guys go check out our recent video where
we got verified actual gamers to compete
against yours truly for a chance to get
a gpu at that elusive msrp actually some
of them even ended up with discounts
they beat me